doug mcgregor is a retired army colonel
former senior adviser to the secretary
of defense he joins us tonight because
he is the one man who can answer the
question who should have known better
doug thanks so much for coming on
tonight um
so you have called for withdrawal from
afghanistan for a long time you gave the
previous administration a detailed
plan for how to do that without the
results that we're seeing today what did
we did our government just do that we
should not have done
well i think there are three things that
we have to take into consideration first
of course
is that there was never an exit strategy
no glide path out of afghanistan
when i was in the pentagon the only
thing i could find out was there was an
intention to stay indefinitely
for some of the reasons that you
outlined in your opening remarks lots of
people were benefiting
not the american people and certainly
not our soldiers and marines
but there was no glide path out of the
place secondly we have these toxic
senior military leaders toxic because
they simply don't tell the truth and for
20 years they have been lying frankly to
the american people to soldiers and
marines who were doing the fighting
telling them that things were getting
better that we were making progress when
the truth was we weren't
and the soldiers and marines can't be
blamed for that they fought very well
let there be no mistake about it but the
generals have done a terrible job and
that's obvious from what you're seeing
on the ground right now the chaos no
planning no preparation
awful i can't think of anything worse
and then finally we went in we said we
were going to fight terrorism as you
pointed out that was over quite quickly
there was no reason to make war on the
taliban had no role in 9 11.
we were there for al qaeda only al qaeda
escaped through the incompetence of
tommy franks and others
but effectively we had pushed them out
of afghanistan and we should have left
we didn't do that
and so what do we got now we don't have
democracy we haven't defeated terrorism
per se we've probably created some new
ones we have the largest narcos state in
the world it is now falling into the
hands of new criminals and new
terrorists
i just
all of that is depressing to hear and i
think verifiably true but i want to go
to the very first point that you made
that after 20 years there was no
specific plan to leave there was no as
you put it glide path how can that be
well when we first went into iraq there
was an argument between rumsfeld and
some others in his office
and finally
paul wolfowitz
interjected and said look we just want
to get the army into iraq
i think there were a lot of people that
decided they just wanted to get the
military into these places and that
somehow or another we would muddle
through
that things would improve you know it
could be said that a generation ends
when its illusions are exhausted i think
it was arthur miller that said that what
you're seeing now on the television this
mass chaos this dissolution
is really the end of the illusions that
began long ago in the aftermath of
desert storm with madeleine albright and
her successors
why aren't we using the army she said to
general colin powell
you keep talking about how good it is
let's use it he obviously was not
excited about seeing it employed for
reasons other than fighting
well
we've employed it and the marine corps
all over the middle east and what have
we created chaos what have we
established this in the interest of the
american people
nothing
they're reckless children you've you've
confirmed it again colonel douglas i
appreciate coming on thank you so much
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else